this video is sponsored by crossing void
global without overdone and tired we all
are of the ISA kai-shan rrah as an anime
fan ik not don't feel like you're
drowning in the pit of the same recycled
ideas the same three protagonist being
transported to the same fantasy world
and if like me you've had multiple
conversations with other anime fans over
this exact topic and at this point I'll
be amazed if you haven't on the odd
occasion you'll meet that one pompous
get who thinks they're being all
original being like you know what would
be cool what if instead of a normal guy
being transported to a fantasy world we
reverse it and have fantasy characters
being transported to our world ha I bet
no one's ever thought of that idea
before ha ha ha nope the devil is a
part-timer is one of those shows that
seems to keep coming up in conversation
every now and then even though on the
surface it seems like one of those
disposable seasonal anime everyone
should have forgotten by now but every
so often some bozo will still come along
and say hey remember devil is a
part-timer do you still think there's a
chance we'll get a season two before
awkward silence fills the room as you
then proceed to hear someone else burst
out crying in no game no life it's a
show that has refused to die in the
hearts of many and having just
re-watched it I can't help a thing that
this is a series that would resonate
with audiences even more today than when
it initially aired because it feels like
a great answer to the current Issei KY
landscape we are so used to right off
the bat drops you into what appears to
be the most bog-standard fantasy world
plotline you have a demon Lord Satan
who's trying to take over the world of
NCES 'la only to be thwarted by the
legendary hero Emilia oh not that one in
desperation he and one of his loyal
generals escapes through a portal to
another world only to find themselves in
modern-day Japan where they walk around
try to speak the language and get hit by
a truck not really but that would have
been pretty funny in a world you've
limited magic and no way to get back
there are only choices to try and
survive in this world by integrating
themselves into society starting by
earning money and getting a part-time
job in McDonald's which if you can guess
is an obvious parody of the global
fast-food powerhouse you should all know
that's right work donald's it's the
story of an Opie demon law 2 gets
transported to the human world where he
works a normal part time job and tries
to climb the corporate ladder to become
king of the McNuggets
lord of the fries aiming for that
employee-of-the-month spot by ensuring
that this is the early
branch in existence with a fully
functioning milkshake machine if you
showed this as someone today they
probably get a Sakai culture shock it
seems like the perfect reply to the
tropes we see in the saturated era of
fantasy world a Sakai but of course this
came out just as the e Sakai boom was
starting and unlike a lot of recent
attempts I've seen that I've tried to
parody the genre it's genuinely
entertaining and funny one of the
biggest thing I've seen that's urged me
recently is when anime has tried
satirizing itself every so often you'll
find this moment in the show that thinks
it's being clever and funny when it
tries to make a joke by calling
attention to this trope you're used to
seeing in anime like hey look and they
could send array in front of me guess
I'm about to get punched and killed oh
well where do they be funny if I didn't
punch you wait you're not gonna punch me
yeah I'm not oh wow I guess that is
pretty funny isn't it this is funny
the entire joke is just in discussing
that you know that thing that normally
happens in anime well that thing you
thought was gonna happen isn't actually
gonna happen non-god on okay meet a coma
I bring this up because while the plot
description can make the devil as a
part-timer seem like an attempt to
satirize the current esky landscape it
never feels like it's actively trying to
do so because it's not this is a six
year old show that came out before there
was established tropes to parody yet
viewing it today it's ironically does a
better job at subverting these cliches
than 90% of these so-called funny meta
moments that actively make an effort to
do so it isn't funny because it's
calling attention to all these tropes we
are used to seeing a nice take I flipped
it's just a very funny situation the
characters find themselves in and they
react in the comedic way but ultimately
stay in character the jokes aren't them
explaining the joke there's an actual
punchline what works is the sheer
ridiculousness of the premise wherein
we're used to seeing a Normie otaku
protagonist doing [ __ ] all in this life
arriving a middle of for some high
stakes world saving quest here the
stakes were reversed and we get to see a
world conquering demon Lords just
dealing with the sheer terror that is
our mundane normal daily grind
it's the classic fish-out-of-water
scenario with a reverse fantasy twist
and yet somehow compared to what we see
today still feels oddly refreshing and
this has helped with a great dynamic
between the cast members Sadao Emilia
Ashiya Chiho Lucifer it isn't just the
fact that the devil is working at a
fast-food restaurant
it's the fact
the cars retains the same dynamics you'd
expect in an epic fantasy story while
having to keep it up in a modern setting
mouths accompanying general Ashiya tries
to remain loyal to him throughout
serving him in any way possible
but of course is no realms for him to
control or armies to command so he
serves him the best way he knows how as
a stay-at-home housewife
then there's Amelia who has to deal with
the internal conflict of finally
confronting the all-powerful 'man Demon
Lord she spent her entire life fighting
only to find that he's actually a normal
hard-working guy unsure if your one day
turn again and has to maintain her world
saving hero status while holding a tele
sales job is the balance that just gives
the car some great chemistry when it
comes to the comedy without making
anything feel forced like a lot of
people may see Emilia as your typical
Cinderella but given the context it does
make sense why he asks you towards maou
is so cold and also I like cinder e's I
don't know why I said that I didn't
really have anything else to add to that
point speaking of Emilia she herself is
a playable character in today's sponsor
crossing void global and I just want to
take a second to talk about that cross
avoid global is an all-star turn-based
RPG with characters from over 25 anime
franchises including devil is a
part-timer index john oliver
toradora spice and wolf or emo sao and
more yes you can collect all your best
boys and girls and upgrade them to do
battles so you know that means use all
the original character moves you are
familiar with including the coasters all
famous railgun Kirito starburst stream
and then his Shizuo just casually
flaring a vending machine you can also
mix and match characters from different
franchises in battle to get their own
unique cross skills and it also includes
an original storyline that crosses over
with all of the multiple franchises and
yes of course if you show your
dedication to your best girl by
upgrading her you can unlock exclusive
illustrations and emotes to celebrate
the release of cross avoid global Alice
from sao will be making her debut and
also if you download it now you can get
any Sta character of your own choice for
absolutely free also crossing voids
Facebook and Twitter pages are holding
regular events so follow their pages for
the latest updates and events if this
sounds like something for you click the
link below to download it on iOS or
Android
getting back to the devil is a
part-timer though it's fairly safe to
say that if that's all there was in the
theories
would surely get dull I've seen enough
anime that have tried to live off of one
running joke alone and the literal devil
getting outrageously fired up and
motivated about selling special Peppard
fries can only go so far
thankfully it does have a semblance of a
plot with the fantasy world they came
from still having a role to play in the
overarching story the war between the
devil and humans never technically ended
and in between the fast-food joints you
have a few arcs focusing on characters
from the fantasy world trying to come
and kill the devil as they always have
it's a great mixture of unique comedy
with a fantasy action backbone to keep
you on your toes and most importantly
keep you entertained having events
interspersed with greater consequence
not only makes the show more interesting
well allows the characters to grow and
evolve as the series goes on of course
while I am throwing a lot of praise if
there was one big downside to this
series is that there isn't really much
more to say about it it was a nice
little fun series that said it's peace
then ended and bi ended what I mean is
they didn't really end it just woke up
the next day it snuck out while you're
still sleeping and didn't even leave a
number for you to contact it by well I
enjoyed the series there's nothing I can
really point you to say wow this was
really amazing but most of that is
because it didn't really have the time
to properly hit it stride or establish
yourself just as you feel the fall stars
progressing and the characters of a
chance to develop the curtains closed
and an announcement comes on saying this
is a show that has been stuck in sequel
limbo for years and it doesn't really
make sense because it was the third
best-selling light novel of that year
and before I just checked I had no idea
that it was the 55th most popular anime
on my anime list putting it above mob
psycho hundreds of Madoka Kayne and Jojo
what the [ __ ] the demand was definitely
there so I can't shake this feeling that
him I have just come out a bit before
it's time because I believe that if it
did actually come out today with season
two and three announcements coming out
for anime big and small sometimes even
right after his shows finished on top of
the sheer abundance and popularity of
ISA Kai being released now there's no
way wouldn't have gotten another season
as his fans the devil is a part-timer is
a short fun little package that didn't
overstay its welcome but we were
definitely welcomed
more of it recently I've had a lot of
fun going back to watch these older
incomplete shows I'd forgotten about
because now there's just an abundance of
new manga chapters and light novels that
can finally fill that void I felt when
they initially aired and I think the
devil is a part-timer has been one
series I've enjoyed even more revisiting
than when I first watched it back when
this first aired I kind of just took it
at face value as this entertaining
little fantasy show and I think I'd even
heard of the word he Sakai back then and
apparently I now say it every other
sentence by law which is why I think
it's a show I can appreciate even more
now and right now I can definitely
recommend this as the perfect time to go
revisit it and if you've never seen it
before well that's all the more reason
to because I think it says a lot about
the current environment when I can say
to you hey want a genuinely fun twist on
the Issa kai-shan row that feels way
more original than 90% of the attempts
coming out now here's this half decade
old anime
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
again I'd really like to thank cross
Android global for sponsoring me today I
don't think I got a chance to say how
awesome I think it is that all of these
different anime franchises are coming
together for this one game and there was
nowhere near enough time to name out all
the IPS that were gonna be in it so if
you want to give it a go and find out
for yourself click the link below to
download it today and with that said I
know the last month has been pretty
barren in terms of video uploads from me
and there is a reason for that I've just
moved to Japan yes I won't bog you down
with all the details but I've finally
fulfilled the weave dream and yeah
that's really kept me busy for the last
few weeks which is the reason I haven't
really uploaded everything and just been
kind of off the grid in general though I
do plan to make up for it this month
though I have a bunch of videos that I
was working on that had to be put on
hold because of the move so expects this
month to be even more busier than usual
in terms of uploads starting with the
seasonal rundown which you can expect
next anyway though that's it from me
I've been gigging and I'll see you all
next time